well we can get more now on the
deployment of thousands of British
troops to Eastern Europe but here with
me now in the studio is Major General
Neil Sexton he's a defense consultant
for Universal defense and Security
Solutions are good to have you uh back
here thank you very much indeed we like
our Maps don't we at Sky News it all
brings it to life actually what is going
on it's like our own situation room here
isn't it with you as an expert to talk
us through it what is happening on the
ground we've spent a lot of time
focusing on this Corridor here
well I think first if I just touch on
Kiev where the Russian mod has announced
that it did carry out missile strikes
yesterday not just in Keith but around
the whole of Ukraine
um and they've said of course that
they're striking military targets and
power stations they haven't mentioned of
course the civilian residential block
that they hit where they've killed at
least one person in Kiev and there are
other casualties but the main fighting
at the moment seems to be still around
the donbass there is some on the south
coast as you say but if we look into the
donbass region over here
um the Russians have now regrouped
analysts are saying around 1992
Battalion tactical groups Each of which
600 to 800 Soldiers with 10 tanks each
and maybe 40 infantry fighting vehicles
and they're
um at the moment severe severe fighting
around severodone-esque there is
significant shelling along the edge of
the Shaded area you can see on the map
there the line of conflict and that has
been extremely difficult for the
Ukrainian Defenders over the last 24
hours but they're managing really well
in World dog well-prepared positions
they've been training for this defense
for eight years and they have carried
out some really good counter-attack
activity on a local level so what that
means is the Russians are failing to
take any ground at all really and
they're definitely failing to link up
between izium in the north coming down
to the south towards the net that was
their plan that's just not working as an
encirclement at the moment yeah they're
big distances as well aren't they so
it's going to take some time with the
rate that they're going out and they're
concerned about their Logistics still
which has been their weakness in the
past and they're moving very slowly and
carefully so that they don't make the
same mistakes
now also a big deployment around 8 000
British soldiers are due to be sent to
Eastern Europe to take part in military
exercises there and it's pretty
significant isn't it the size of the
department it is now these are just
where they are these are pre-planned
exercises long planned and the British
army is constantly training overseas
with partners and what we've seen today
is an announcement of an enhancement of
those exercises because of the Ukraine
situation uh at the moment in Finland
we've got a squadron of the Queen's
Royal azars that is embedded with a
Finnish armored battle group the British
Challenger 2 tanks working alongside the
fins there under the joint expeditionary
force headmark that is the uk-led task
force that was designed at the NATO
conference in 2014. if I come further
south a very significant exercise of
some 2 000 British troops in the Estonia
and Latvia border region two battle
groups from the Royal Welsh and the
Royal tank regiment Challenger tank
again Warrior infantry fighting Vehicles
alongside about 18 000 troops from other
nations as part of the NATO enhanced
forward presence deployment that's been
there since 2017. and then other
exercises later in May and into the uh
into the summer defender in Poland a
very large exercise a thousand British
troops there alongside 11 other NATO
Nations deploying from bases our bases
in the UK and Germany tanks into Poland
and lastly but it's not insignificant as
well a deployment this week of the UK's
aerosol Brigade into Macedonia along
with Chinook and Apache helicopters and
with your expertise uh and your hat on
here your military hat on
um how significant a message is this
sending well it sends a message of
consistent deterrence and partnership
across NATO it indicates as I've said
that the strengthening of our enhanced
forward presence since 2017 has been up
uh One More Level it shows that the
British military is absolutely involved
in nato in a leadership role and it's
demonstrating that we can deploy our
troops reinforce our troops from the UK
and from their storage bases uh in
Germany very interesting okay Major
General Neil Sexton I think we're going
to be speaking to you again later in the
program but for now thank you very much